I have a few questions. Can I go to the dentist and get treatment health delete? Is it dangerous? I know I have
cavities that possibly root cadels need it. So first of all, I wouldn't get any root cadels
personally. You know, it's hard to do that. Whether it's a front tooth or something like that. But,
you know, there's just dangers in getting root cadels. I think I have some articles on the blog post
so you could certainly Google lots of dangers in root cadels articles out there by a good biological
dentist. If a person if you're fairly healthy, you know, you're not like, you know, super, super sick
with your cancer, certainly you should go to the dentist and you should get your teeth, you know,
cared for. You should go try your best to go to a biological dentist who will not even recommend
root cadels, though. So find a biological dentist in your area would be my first choice because
you want to get proper dentistry, not just that, not just regular dentistry. Can I take sour
salt leaves to boil to make tea? I don't know the answer to that. Honestly, I don't know. I've
not ever done that. I've not had anybody do that. Nobody tell me that they were doing that. So I do
not know the answer to that. I heard it's really good at getting rid of cancer. Yeah, I don't, I wish
I'll do some investigation on that, but I don't know. Can I, yeah, or is this pushing it for me?
No, Yams has a very low glycemic index, so you'd be fine eating it. That would be fine. That would be
a good source of some calories.